so I'm sitting here doing my email
actually kind of prepping for my show
that I'm about to tape for Wine Library
TV and go through my email and once
again I get another email that I get all
the time Gary how do i monetize my blog
how do we make money on my video blog
how do we make money um doing what we do
my show how do I make money where am I
gonna make money I need to make money
I get it it makes sense monetizing is
where it's at my friends that's why you
have to do it and that's why you need to
think about it in a very simple concise
way the way you're gonna make money
online and by the way anywhere but
especially right now as social media is
developing and our shows and different
shows that there are building a fanbase
and we have to convince the buying
public the advertisers out there the way
you're gonna make money while the big
boys are maybe out of your league or
you're not ready to give a PowerPoint
presentation and wear a tie and go to
Madison Avenue the when you're gonna
make money is by grabbing it and let me
show you exactly because I get this
email all the time I'm actually making
this garyvaynerchuk.com
to be selfish so I can send this link to
every person that emails me about this
because I get this email 16 to 18 times
a day um the way you want to make money
is by grabbing it so if I were you I
would do this I would go to Google not
zoom it in time baby let's zoom it in
here beautiful I would go to Google and
let's say you've got a beer show I would
type in beer and then what I would do is
I would look over here so look beer you
know there are all these beer sites all
these different peer sites and I would
look and I would look at what they are
and so here's you know different coach
custom beer glasses so I would click
this one pop glasses comm sorry pop
glasses calm
I just cost you a couple cents but it's
all in the world in the word of
community and helping people I go to
this site I see what they have they have
a lot of different things that clothing
they've all this stuff they're in Austin
Texas there's small businesses
well and if I had a video show about
beer that had 700 900 even 2,000 viewers
or if I had a beer blog I would find
that the phone number of this place
that's what I would do I would find it
out about scroll down here you go here's
a phone number I'd pick it up four five
eight four four three eight this is
super live
I have not set these guys I don't even
know why I'm doing this right now but I
would call them and I would ask them
about advertisement hello who would I
speak to about you guys possibly up
advertising on my beer blog that's me
the owner of Dean Dean who are you this
is Gary Vaynerchuk I run a wine blog on
the Internet and I'm thinking about
launching a beer blog sure okay and um
I'm wondering if if I was able to build
up my audience to it you know two or
three thousand people daily would your
site have interest in maybe buying
advertising we're being a you know
sponsor of a show to to bring attention
to your pub glasses calm website
possibly whether you're I'm not sure you
know I'm just trying to gauge I mean I
saw that you advertised on Google so I'm
just trying to gay I'm actually
recording this to try to figure out if
this is like a good way to like but you
know get sponsorship but I'm gonna try
to build up some audience and then I
will reach out to you with with you know
real numbers so I'm not just jerking
your chain you know what I mean okay
yeah with Google's the premiere way to
advertise just because people are
actively searching for something no
question have I hit him in the face with
oh I think I think you're doing a great
job I think that if I have you know 500
to 2,000 people watching a 20 minute
beer show every single day that they're
obviously gonna be very targeted
advertising for and maybe we can you
know I mean Google you know who knows
what their intent is when they search
and you're paying for it but if I've got
you know fifteen hundred two thousand
beer aficionados watching my show 20
minutes a day every day that there's a
chance that they'll go out and you know
and that's a very targeted audience for
you yeah but I
yeah there's and the thousands of owe
millions of who the my friends we we
come up on Google but anyway yeah
whenever you get it up and running I'll
be glad to talk to you about a little
more increasing I really like to push
the personalized wine glasses and I can
that it's not really feasible doing it
out of state but we personalize wine
bottles I have some here it's a wine
bottle that someone brought me they're
giving it as a dip so we etch you know
thank you or Happy Holidays happy
birthday whatever n [ __ ] right onto the
full bottle of wine that's awesome so I
mean you know one of the things that we
could do advertising wise is if I have a
lot of people watching the show maybe we
can do some sort of affiliate deal where
any any lead that comes from me you
could pay me on that okay okay well I'll
get my stuff rolling and then we'll
reach out okay
alright take care thank you my my my you
like that right I stepped up that was
pretty cool right
so anyway I mean at the end of the day I
had no intentions of doing that and that
could have gone you know really poorly
and obviously you could see he was like
Google is to permeate you know so he's
got his ways but you got to convince
them you see I didn't just give up and
say oh okay Google you got to tell them
what you possibly can do maybe you could
do an affiliate program so obviously
that's just one little box might get
back in here one little box on Google
there are a ton of boxes than that you
know there are just a ton of different
things I mean it could be about anything
maybe you're into Smurfs maybe I always
talk about doing small things like
Smurfs so let's top it up let's put in
Smurfs MOT I mean let's zoom in here
take a look at this here we go
a lot of Yahoo you got to look through
Toys R Us obviously we're knocking at
orser's but here's our citize RC toys
calm RC toys here it is they sell Smurf
figurines they've got a blog so what
would I do I call their toll-free number
and I'd reach out and I would spend five
to ten times the time that I spend on
putting out a show or content on going
out and finding sponsors and selling
them on the rationale to why you're
better off if I'm doing a Smurfs show
and I have 1800 viewers that's nothing
right there's tens of thousands of
people using Google but at the end
but at the end of the day the fact that
matters is that it's very targeted and I
could probably convince our citize for
at least an affiliate program or
something of that nature and you've just
got to go out there and hustle you've
got to go out there and find people or
let's say you're in the technology space
I would go to a site like TechCrunch or
centered networks and I would go to
their site you see a lot of these sites
out there guys where you look and they
show you your sponsors so if Rackspace
and crush plan Pro and go grid and you
know lay web are advertising on these
sites and then I would go to you know
but you know senator net barks comm and
I go to this site and I would look and I
would see oh look he's got boxes so
what's cloud contacts not let's zoom in
on cloud contacts you know so what I
would do guys if I was in the technology
space there's a very neat little site
called pop URLs if you don't know it you
should check it out pop URLs pop PLP URL
Escom um and if you go to the bottom
there's something called quickies and
voices and I would click every one of
these sites because these are cool
little important sites and I would see
who's advertising there you know and I
would link up to and go after them cold
calling asking people convincing them
why MySpace and what I do is valuable to
them just like I did right there if you
want ad revenue and you can't get to the
big boys yet and Madison Avenue isn't
ready for it yet and you're a niche then
Google your way to finding the people
that are advertising in your space and
sell them and grab it you've got to take
it that's how you're gonna get